If Jonathan winters was never accused of
anything,
he's got the perfect alibi.
He was someone else at the time when I
first saw him before the show,
and he was still trying to decide
whether he could be a drunken Eskimo,
the queen of the Vikings,
or a door knob.
I'd read it.
He came out to begin with because when
he's johnny winter cannot be in the
wild,
wild man,
my friend Jonathan with
in my opinion,
it's impossible to understand the genius
of the late Robin Williams without first
understanding the corresponding genius
of his idol.
Jonathan winters.
Winters was the master of
improvisational comedy from the early
days of TV in his standup and various
sketch appearances on talk shows.
What he did was never scripted.
The characters he invented.
The scenes he enacted were plucked from
the air in front of his eyes.
The kids had some candy and nation that
did that.
They come to the river.
There's a barrier here and we will get
some pictures of the bear.
The bear ate together,
but we got some wonderful backdrop.
One of winters,
most famous and simplest bits was called
the stick from the Jack Paar.
What can you do a routine with you?
Give them anything.
Why am I went to a pretty good cash when
I grind time,
Margaret bloody dogs just up there,
just this side of the green trailers.
Seven years later,
another comedian did a very similar
routine with a Pashmina on inside the
actor's studio.
I came to Bombay.
Yeah,
we are going to cook octopus football.
Williams and Jonathan winters were
kindred spirits.
They work together for the first time on
the TV show.
Mork and mindy winters played his son,
from which point they remained great
friends until winters death in 2013,
only a year and change it.
Turns out before Robin Williams took his
own life in this clip from a 60 minutes
profile on winters,
it's Robin Williams who expresses the
great lesson that his mentor taught him.
What was indeed the great philosophy of
both their comedians.
Jonathan has just taught me about the
world is open for play,
is that anything and everybody is
marketable in a wonderful way.
This,
that the world
is open for play.
It's an extremely rich one.
It suggests rightly that humanity and
our shared reality is made up of fluid
elements of language and social
structures which are sometimes codified
into rules and pressures and laws,
but that even the most rigid feature of
what man makes can be turned flexible
again and malleable again and funny with
play winters and Williams saw reality
for its basic elements and felt a grand
freedom in their work to rearrange those
elements into hilarious parodies of our
world.
Gosh,
I was so taken with this guy.
I was when I first first met him and I'm
working Monday.
We we did.
We had a marvelous time.
Your good days,
you had access to more medication and
will
williams exceeded.
Even the master was in his dramatic
scope.
Not only could he create exaggerations
of character in his comedy,
but he had the ability to reproduce the
subtleties of character as well.
Feeling like God put an angel on earth
for you to rescue you from the depths of
hell when you wouldn't know what it's
like to be arranged,
to have that love for her to be there
forever.
In the end,
both talents reflect the same empathetic
observation of people,
winters and Williams like no one else
before or since understood the
stereotypes in subtlety and the subtlety
and exaggeration.
It may seem as if this sublime energy of
play passes away with them,
but of course the opposite is true.
We have that energy for all time because
they gave it to us,
reverend angel,
my hands or our credit because you can
tell,
but I just consider him not as hands
anymore,
but his paws.
And be ready to do this.
Get a little cat tree.
Don't be afraid.
My hands on your head now,
but they're in my hands.
Why would you put your hand on my head?
Because that's not the America.
Go with me to work with.
Work with my demon spirit.
Bobby.
Get the extra hands straight out.
Straight out.
Now you can serve things.
Go table 14.
Able.
Oh Man,
I can't get them back that way.
How do you get them back for it?
Look horrible.
This is called [inaudible] Syndrome.
A tendency to be in a box for no reason,
for horrible long periods and of to walk
against the wind when there is no win.
Why don't you please help a as a
terrible thing to waste?
You're really saying,
not me as a terrible look at this.
This also means surrender.
So,
so basically the Egyptian army training
course.
Okay,
ready?
Drop gun again.
One time that I've done.
Okay,
gotten all this money.